my name is anthony buchan and i'm a
developer relations engineer here at
google welcome to yet another episode of
gke essentials
[Music]
today's episode is part two of our intro
to building large-scale gk clusters so
let's dive right back in
in part one we discussed why you might
consider building larger kubernetes
clusters with hundreds if not thousands
of nodes
we also covered how to think about your
usage of the kubernetes api and its
resources when doing so
if you haven't seen it take a look at
the link in the description below and
come back to this video after
in part two we'll dig into how to think
about your usage of gke and foundational
google cloud resources when building a
large-scale gke cluster
let's break down four categories where
you can get started
[Music]
the first is designing your cluster to
be highly available
this uptime that we look for from our
cluster can be viewed from a couple of
perspectives
one continued uptime for the
infrastructure that runs our workload
and two continued uptime for the
kubernetes control plane which you as an
operator may interact with regularly
the next is working through networking
to ensure its various pieces can scale
with your cluster
this includes ip address management dns
and load balancing
third we want to make sure that we can
enable our workloads ensuring that they
have the resources that they need but
also do not contend with one another
finally we want to ensure that quotas
and limits are appropriately set to
support large-scale gke clusters
together applying practices across these
four areas of considerations make a
great starting point to building
large-scale clusters in gke
let's now talk about those practices
when building for high availability in
gke you'll have considerations both at
the control plane and the no level for
your workload
regional clusters in gke are recommended
for achieving high availability
with regional clusters by default there
are three replicas of your control plane
each in a different zone of a region
this protects your control plane against
any zonal outage
it also provides high availability
during your upgrade lifecycle as
replicas of the control plane are
upgraded one at a time with the
remaining two still available to serve
requests
this means that operators and pipelines
can continue to interact with the
kubernetes api even during upgrades
regional clusters also provide high
availability at the node pool level
allowing for the allocatable resources
like cpu and memory for your workloads
to actually be distributed across zones
paired with gke support for regional
persistent disks this makes your
workloads stateless or stateful
resilient across multiple failure
domains
of course there are corner cases where
you may need a workload only in one
specific zone for workloads that are
latency sensitive or need specialized
resources like gpus that are only
available in a single zone
gke supports creating a no pool in a
subset of the region zones as well
now let's talk about what we need to
consider with care on everyone's
favorite topic networking
in gke there are specific practices you
can use to handle potential issues
around ip address management and dns
scalability
you should also be cognizant of what
load balancers your tenants will require
in order to prepare your cluster
accordingly
at this scale we'll have many workloads
running in a single gke cluster
and in a gke cluster every single one of
those pods gets an ip address
this can actually make planning around
ip address allocation tricky especially
when considering that not wasting ipv4
address space is top of mind
gke provides two features that can help
you tackle this
flexible pod sider and discontiguous
multi-pod side
flexible pod sider allows for you to
reduce the number of ip addresses each
node has to give to pods which allows
for less waste
this contiguous multipod slider allows
for you to grow the ip address space
that you allocate to a cluster
incrementally as you add new node pools
each of these features can help you
tackle ip address management in a large
scale gke cluster
cluster dns also requires attention at
large scale
by default kube dns runs as a deployment
in your gke cluster with its own auto
scaler
at scale this can become a bottleneck as
more workloads in the same cluster
generate more request load to this coop
dns service
in gke you can enable node local dns
cache which deploys a daemon to each
node to serve cached dns responses to
pods
this relieves pressure on cube dns as
only cache misses hit the centralized
service gke also supports a fully
managed cluster dns infrastructure with
cloud dns for gke
this removes dns resolution from the
cluster's infrastructure and utilizes a
fully managed platform cloud dns instead
finally you'll want to plan for what
workloads will need from a load
balancing perspective to expose their
workloads to clients
for layer 7 load balancers both internal
and external configurations are best
supported at scale when using vpc native
clusters
this makes pod ips natively routable in
your vpc instead of utilizing routing
tables and is the default configuration
for all clusters in the 121 patch listed
and newer
for layer 4 external load balancers
these are only supported in clusters up
to 1000 nodes
this is often the default service type
for in-cluster proxies like nginx so
it's important to know what your
tenant's workloads may need here
finally for layer 4 internal load
balancers there is a 250 node limitation
which can be circumvented when enabling
gke subsetting in your cluster
this is a feature in gke that
automatically partitions the back ends
of your cluster into groups that allow
you to scale the cluster beyond 250
nodes with layer 4 internal load
balancers now let's talk about how you
can best support your tenant workloads
for starters you'll want to ensure that
the nodes you create can adequately
support your workload requirements
once you've designed the node pools
appropriately you can then design a
strategy around the workload's
permissions and potential optimization
node pool design has sets of
configurations that are relevant to how
your workloads run on the nodes in the
node pool
for one if cluster auto scaling is
enabled at the cluster level you still
have the option to choose which node
pools are eligible to auto scale
this is especially important for
workloads that utilize horizontal pod
auto scaling
can the nodes that support the powder
quest from these pods auto scale as well
machine types are also critical in gke
you have the opportunity to create
multiple node pools potentially from
different machine families
depending on your workloads you may find
better performance from compute or
memory optimized instances or even our
new t2d instances when optimizing for
price performance
it's important to consider traits of the
machines underneath the surface level as
well with network bandwidth being a
critical one
all pods on a given node share the same
underlying network bandwidth
this network bandwidth is a function of
the amount of cpu available to the
machine
so it's important to think about how
much networking bandwidth each node will
get and if you have networking intensive
workloads considering isolating those to
their own nodes or node pools
this goes the same for disk performance
the more cpu on the machine the better
performance your workload experience
and there is an additional consideration
with disk as well
as each kubernetes persistent volume is
a new disk mounted to the underlying
node
each node then has a maximum number of
disks that it can have mounted at a
single time
so when considering creating
purpose-built node pools to isolate
specific workloads you can use
functionality such as node selectors and
node affinity to direct workloads to
these node pools
in combination with taints and
tolerations you can effectively reserve
node pools for specific workloads
repelling any workloads not meant for
that node pool's resources
once the foundation of your workload's
infrastructure has been settled you can
then move on to other best practices or
optimizations including granting
granular gcp permissions to workloads
with workload identity
reducing startup latency for pods using
gke image streaming
or implementing gke usage metering to
understand how efficiently teams run
their workloads in your cluster
and finally we wrap with gcp quotas
this is the consideration for how your
gke cluster interacts with various
quotas or limits in gcp at scale
two of the places to start would be
adjusting the compute engine api and the
logging and monitoring apis
as your cluster gets larger there are
more read or list requests made to the
compute engine api from the gke cluster
similarly the more workloads you run in
your node pools the more logs and
metrics are inserted into google cloud
operations
that wraps up our two-part introduction
to building large-scale clusters in gke
keep in mind that this introduction
covered areas where you should focus
your design
to learn more about these principles
check out the link to our published
reference guide
not only will you find more information
on these specific topics but also the
process for getting the google team's
help to create clusters larger than 5000
nodes in gke
thank you for your time and we'll see
you on the next episode of gke
essentials
[Music]
you